all right everyone calm down YouTube
heroes isn't the worst idea ever it's
just a middle-of-the-road idea with good
intentions that fails to read the optics
of the situation and inadvertently
insults most of the content creators on
YouTube before we can start let's make
sure that everyone is up to speed on
what exactly YouTube heroes is late in
the evening on September 20th YouTube
unveiled a new program that would be
starting up in the vague near future
called YouTube heroes the program would
reward participants with points for
activities such as correctly reporting
community standards violating content
adding subtitles captions and
descriptions to videos and participating
in the YouTube heroes section of the
YouTube creators community which I think
I need to explain because I'm pretty
sure you've never heard of it before so
YouTube has its own forum called YouTube
creators community found at the
horrifying URL ww YouTube - creator
community com this feature is so poorly
faced that it doesn't even show up in
the first page of Google searches for
YouTube creator community and Google
owns it in fact to get there organically
you have to go to youtube.com slash YT /
creators and then it's not at the top
navigation bar nor is it in the footer
you need to follow a link in the body of
the page to the Creator community where
you are immediately served with an error
message saying node not found I am not
joking this is not a joke well it is a
joke but not that kind of joke whatever
okay
so YouTube heroes community is intended
to be a subsection of the impossible to
reach YouTube creators community site
and it's just a forum that's literally
all it is it functions almost exactly
like discourse or a text only subreddit
or Yahoo Answers people post stuff and
there's upvotes so by participating in
these three key areas flagging content
like pornography or animal abuse
submitting subtitles and captions and
posting on the heroes forum youtube
heroes will earn points and earning
points in turn confers privileges it's
an RPG leveling system transparently the
whole thing is an attempt at gamifying
the more monotonous aspects of YouTube
so we're just going to describe it like
a video game
I mean they called it YouTube heroes for
God's sake at the lowest level heroes
have scrub class features like access to
the dashboard and forums at level 2
which only requires 10 XP heroes unlock
workshops and live hangouts so basically
a knowledge base like whatever this is
barely a reward at level 3 is when
things catch people's attention access
to so called super tools like the
ability to mass flag content for
standard violations and the ability to
moderate community content that right
there is what's got a lot of people up
in arms but it's not site-wide comment
moderation' power it's only moderation
power on the youtube heroes community
that bad hard to find forgotten forum
that i mentioned earlier also the mass
flagging tool still requires that a
human at youtube confirms the content
for community violations just the same
as if you reported them one by one right
now we'll discuss the implications of
all of these in a bit so moving on level
4 at 400 XP unlocked sneak previews of
upcoming YouTube features and the
contentious vague promise of a direct
line to actual flesh-and-blood humans
working at YouTube put a pin in that one
to level 5 at a whopping thousand XP
gives you access to product beta tests
essentially allowing you to do even more
unpaid work for YouTube and the ability
to apply for the hero summit which is a
party probably in Anaheim almost
certainly in California and you're
likely responsible for getting yourself
there and back again and probably
finding a place to stay too
so onto the contentious parts first the
super tools these are the kind of things
that sound good but don't really do
anything meaningful
it's a tiny amount of sequestered power
the mod powers on the forums could be
abused but it's a forum no one really
cares about anyway so the worst case
scenario is some weird niche internet
drama where a power-hungry mod goes on a
deleting spree before being stripped and
banned an hour later I mean it's still a
bad idea but it's not a monumentally
awful idea the mass flagging tool is
right for abuse but it's not an abuse
that creators are likely to see in ways
that they don't already obsessive
stalkers will already chain report all
of your videos this is technically
making harassment slightly easier but
it's already so easy to harass people on
YouTube that it's not worth the effort
to get to level 3 just to savior
the clicks you could spend time
submitting subtitles just to level up or
you could spend that time filing false
reports and making burner accounts to
file more false reports still though
this one does give me the biggest pause
because even disregarding the mass
flagging tool it is actively
incentivizing flagging videos for
content violations and the higher the
volume of videos reported the more false
positives by incentivizing the system
there's a good chance that they're going
to draw the attention of bad actors in
greater numbers so while it doesn't make
it any easier to be awful on YouTube
because it's already super easy to be
awful on YouTube there is a chance that
it will make awfulness a bit more common
and finally the direct line to human
beings at YouTube the simple reality is
that this is going to be a dead end I
fully expect that anyone who manages to
reach this level is going to find that
line woefully understaffed and responses
to be functionally indistinguishable
from automated responses still the fact
that they are offering that type of
support and access to the volunteers
entering subtitles has rightly pissed
off many content creators many of whom
have decade old channels in good
standing hundreds of thousands of
subscribers but still have trouble ever
contacting a real person / serious
issues like fraudulent and malicious
takedown orders and this is why I say
the biggest issue of YouTube heroes is a
failure to read the optics of the
situation the goal of YouTube heroes is
to get more people consistently taken
care of boring grunt work like entering
captions and subtitles that one thing
right there is at the core of it go back
and look at the XP rewards for each
activity one point for correctly flag
video meaning that you flagged it and a
YouTube employee confirmed it was in
fact porn or animal abuse 10 points for
being the best answer poster on a forum
thread or one point per line of accepted
captioning or subtitling for a reference
point my no man's sky review has over a
hundred and thirty lines of captions
reporting things like snuff films and
pornography and nudity that's not
properly age gated that's also grunt
work crap that they just need more
people doing but at the end of the day
it's all about those captions and
subtitles that's where all of the XP is
which you may notice is a very boring
and unsexy job see captions and
subtitles should be the responsibility
of content creators in broadcast
is the responsibility of the producers
to deliver appropriate closed captioning
and regionalised versions of their
content whether that be dubbed or
subtitled but YouTube doesn't have the
leverage to demand that people do that
they're not Netflix or Hulu so it falls
to a volunteer basis and this is one of
the holes of capitalism accessibility
options are rarely directly profitable
enough for producers to invest in
without being compelled by an outside
force YouTube already isn't profitable
at all for all but a tiny sliver of
users I'm not talking about the 1% I'm
talking about the point zero zero zero
one percent compounding this
accessibility is only valuable at
saturation if 1 percent of popular
English videos have Spanish subtitles
it's not going to draw in more Spanish
users but if someone can click on any
given front page video and have pretty
reasonable odds that there will be
Spanish subtitles that changes the value
same thing with closed captioning for
the hearing impaired it's such a
monumental task that it's not
financially feasible to hire people to
do it here's where the videos are
uploaded every day they would never be
able to catch up even if they only stuck
to the few thousand most popular videos
on any given day so it's a thing that
has very low market value but a huge
value to the people who make use of it
people who don't speak the dominant
language or who are hearing impaired
incentivizing volunteer captioners isn't
the worst idea in the world YouTube does
technically stand to benefit monetarily
from the effort but at the end of the
day not that much so the reality that we
live in is that either a volunteer force
donates their time to improving
accessibility or it never gets done so
YouTube did something sensible they took
a boring job and they dressed it up in a
fancy suit and added prizes where they
failed was specifically in considering
how the framing of those prizes would be
perceived by the content creators who
have long been frustrated by the lack of
diverse and meaningful moderation tools
at their disposal
that's super tool the one that grants
you moderation powers remember that no
one knows YouTube's creator community is
even a thing so watching this
[Music]
is it any wonder that people just
assumed they were going to hand out
site-wide comment moderation' power to
randos how does that look I as a channel
owner still can't deputize comment
moderators like I can on twitch
discourse WordPress reddit or discuss
without giving them full access to the
entire YouTube account and you're just
going to hand out powers to people who
get enough points playing your minigame
well it's no surprise that people
interpret it that way and immediately
got pissed off having said that though
while it is totally understandable and I
do not in any way want to downplay the
very real complaints that content
creators have about the poor resources
available to them at the end of the day
this YouTube heroes program is an okay
idea it just it needs a bit of tweaking
and some much much much better
communication about what exactly they're
giving people power to do like your
subscribe